efore okay yeah let's go with thee for
all right it's Sicilian well no with the
open sister oh no no I should have
played the Alpen that's right officer
remember that I want to learn more about
that so I'm gonna play it more learn
more about an opening by may be planning
it more messing around with that night
ARF all right Wow have some experience
with this oh no I think one of the last
five live commentaries that I posted to
the YouTube channel was with this and it
ended up in a time scramble I was worse
off though for pretty much the whole
game it was against T night I don't know
if T night is here but um I was a really
strong game played by T night on chess
cube so now I have maybe g4 available to
me 'if I've is the one that's most
common I believe be five and then the
night runs away the bishop plays here to
watch over d5
let's go g4 g4 and then what about be 5
g 4e 5 9 @ v g6 g5 pon takes Knight pawn
takes Knight I think that that would
actually be alright
g4 f e5 is played I play Knight here and
then if g6 I could always play this no
that should be I'm gonna try it I
haven't run all the calculations as you
can probably tell by how I was fumbling
up my words but it looks pretty nuts not
my type of game by the way to get crazy
but um I'm okay with getting a little
bit crazy every now and then let's see
who could throw the heavier punches
that's the kind of situation we're in
here it could blow right up at any
moment
okay black says hang on you're not
playing g5 so fast
I understand let's play Bishop e2 so
that this isn't a possibility well it
still is a possibility my main thing is
that if it is kicked away I'm at least
supporting this and I will be taking my
own advice and not playing my rook here
but rather playing h4 first if I'm
trying to get this move in and that no I
think I do well to play this right now
age 4 going all in the chips are pushed
in these types of violent positions do
not end in a truce too often do they now
what about rook here let's do it g5 that
night is gonna have to find a new home
very soon
and I don't know if playing to d7 is
going to be a wonderful square to go to
because when I'm threatening after g5 is
g6 undermining this structure I here and
if this tension is still well if my
night is still around on d4 chopper
ruski on e6 II and then that's that's
that's a disaster for Team black
I'm castling queenside Oh or haven't
it's blowing up right now d5
it's getting pretty nuts right now oh
it's getting that's okay so what do you
do if it gets nuts
you just take here first and then push
okay I'm gonna have to do that if I push
the knight he just chops the pun and
then I'm having to fight back being down
upon in some way now how does black
recapture I think with the knight is
best if you go with the palm that the
knight gets kicked away and then I chop
here I'm on the Queen okay and that's
what we're having I don't have very many
choices I can't I can't allow Knight
takes bishop this guy is too valuable to
give up so oh man Queen d2 queenside
castle seems like it seems like it's a
necessity
Bishop b4 I have c3 nice and easy there
boom important detail if this pawn isn't
on the board if he is let's say over
here absent Bishop b4 and it's time to
kill the king king is dead so what what
is why do Bishop e7 Bishop d6 Bishop c5
Bishop c5 probably runs it to tactics
because it's unprotected from that
square the first tactic that comes to
mind is Knight to e6 Forks and if Bishop
takes Bishop I can actually recapture
you know if blacks trying to get clever
with Bishop here Knight here takes
well no no no wait wait a second Bishop
here a night here I take the Queen with
check okay I have to do that
Bishop Tate it's not just the threat of
Bishop takes Queen its Bishop takes
Queen width check it's very unlikely
that there's going to be an in-between
move force for that so do I push here I
think I'm just helping that rook out
night here no I'm not gonna do that I'm
gonna get castled if I'm gonna play here
I'm gonna do that only after the bishop
has moved I don't want it to be able to
go from point A to point B you'll see
this often times in a Queens gambit
declined with the LightSquared Bishop on
f1 supporting the c4 pawn black will
wait to capture on c4 wait wait for the
light-square bishop to move before
capturing on c4 and now I have the
possibility of chopping this Bishop and
maybe getting a piece here to give check
to the King I don't know if I have time
to do that
actually you know what I'm gonna try
this um this is something I was
referencing earlier with undermining
this I was referencing the pawn
structure but I could still undermine
now this Bishop with g6
and here we go so this rook is
guaranteed some play on the G file right
now where is he or is he do I really
want to well what do I want to do I
don't know I do I want to take the
bishop or allow my rook to come to life
here I'm pretty sure I'm in a better
position right here right now my
opponent is working with an isolated
pawn if I take with my Bishop Bishop
here and I'm having to come back taking
with my queen my my queen is going to
get kicked away let me do this and
Bishop here I have to come back and whoa
I'm getting very active right now I
think f6 was the correct move
believe I take here I'm on the bishop
and the pond this capture right here is
helping out two of my pieces whereas the
f6 move shuts down two of my pieces this
is a huge turning point right here I'm
sure there were other improvements
earlier on
now it's trembling that's just a slip-up
seeing the one strap up missing the
other easy to do if you're new to chest
and you're not familiar or if you're you
know if you're if you're new to chest
these time constraints will get the best
of anybody I could take this and just
well I'm gonna play no no no wait yeah
I'm gonna do this it's a nice home for
my bishop and I'm seeing as a follow up
f3 but there's no need to do that I want
to be able to maintain my dark square
Bishop spoke with Bishop to e3 in
response to Bishop to f4 so as a follow
up f3 I think everything is nice and
secure and we have resignation so a good
game let's back up because I think there
are some interesting alternatives
especially towards that end that
decision to take on g6 there's going to
be an improvement on that ok backing up
let's see what those improvements are so
and before I forget let me do this
this is this is tough for me to remember
apparently so looking for my opponents
end and this is with the Sicilian here 9
ourf this is I think the most common
move to go with e5 but um if you could
still be dealing with this and now we
have ok g4 which is trying to be
disruptive to this night maybe mess with
the black coordination for example if in
response to g4 right now if black played
Knight to d7 well guess what after after
g5 the night
is gonna have to say I'm going home
because the d7 square is not available
so something something needs to be done
about this
d5 being pressed in the center right now
you know this this comes only like it's
very very timely it's happening just
before the night is gonna have to be
maybe kicked backwards if I do it right
now after d5 if I played g5 right now
I'm just losing this pawn might be
compensation for it but I didn't want to
have to enter that sort of a territory
where I'm having to show compensation
for being down upon it I felt that I I
could just play on an equal material
type of position just follow through
with the rest of my development bump the
queen up king or a queen side castle and
this is the correct recapture otherwise
I push and then take here I'm on the
Queen that's probably not a good thing
right here I don't know if I really do
stand a whole lot better right now this
right here this right here I think it is
a necessity to play f6 what is f6 do it
shuts down my rook my rook is staring at
upon and my bishop is staring it upon
you capture after just a single move now
my bishop has a wonderful prospects as
does my rook not only along the file
anymore but look at the horizontal
movement that's what ended up you know
there's a blender made right there
dropping the bishop but right here you
definitely need to do something like f6
taking into account both the Brooke
activity and the bishop activity that'll
uh that'll fix both of those that will
give you less to worry about